we just found out three separate bomb
shells from the Broward County Sheriff's
Office and they are all good reason why
you will never want to give up your guns
to the authorities we'll explain all of
it I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
if the reports that we are now reading
from CNN are true this is the most
shocking law enforcement failure in
modern American history and it is not
close I'm gonna bring you all the news
about what's going on out of Broward
County just shameful shameful horrifying
nonsense but first I want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at movement
watches so you know how much I like my
movement watches I have two of them they
are fantastic they are top-notch they
are clean they look good they're cleanly
designed they last when my son beats the
crap out of them they work just fine the
next day they are fantastic all the way
through they've come pretty far from
being a bunch of crowdfunding kids
working out of a living room they've
introduced a ton of new watch
collections for both men and women but
they've also expanded as sunglasses in
fashion for bracelets for women as well
I've bought one of these watches from my
wife bought one for my mom they're just
fantastic movement watches are all about
looking good and keeping it simple and
they start at just $95 at a department
store for these kind of watches looking
at four to five hundred bucks movement
figured out they can cut out the
middleman
and now they can give it directly to you
and right now if you go to MVM t.com
slash shapiro you get 15% off today when
you use that slash up hero MVM t.com
slash apparel free shipping free returns
there's a reason mbm t keeps growing a
lot of my fans have movement watches now
they come up to me and they show me
their movement watches and they're all
super happy with them and the MT comm
slash apparel again it's MVM t.com slash
appear on what the slash repair you let
them know we set you and you get 15% off
your order today with free shipping and
free returns they are fantastic again I
own two of them and it looks forward
buying more of them in the future
actually movement watches sort of made
me a watch junkie so now I've been
buying watches specifically because
they're so affordable and they are so
nice go join the movement
MVM t.com slash Shapiro MVM t.com slash
apparel all right so here is the
breaking news well let me step back for
a second before I get to the breaking
news actually so you got remember a
couple of nights ago the on CNN there's
a 2-hour town hall and this town hall
special was specifically designed to
make gun owners members of the NRA
Second Amendment advocates feel as
though they were morally inferior as
though these people were somehow
responsible for the horrors of what had
happened inside that school over in
parkland Florida and all that was
nonsense of course the sheriff of
Broward County Scott Israel did this
beating of his chest and it's wailing
and gnashing of teeth blending the NRA
and the availability of ar-15s well now
we know exactly why this shooting
happened and it happened because
authorities failed on every single level
all of them it wasn't just the FBI got
two calls and did nothing it wasn't just
the Broward County Sheriff's Office
received 39 separate calls to this
piece-of-crap tome over the course of
seven years when just that now we have
even more information you ready for this
we want to talk bombshells here the
bombshells on Thursday night the
American public learned that Broward
County Sheriff's Office was told in
November then the Periclean shooter quit
quote could be a school shooter in the
making but deputies didn't bother to
write up a report that report came just
weeks after a relative called urging the
BSO the Broward County Sheriff's Office
to seize his weapon then here's the even
more shocking news we learned that an
armed school resource officers when it's
just mind-boggling an armed school
resource officer and Marjory Stoneman
Douglas High School sat outside and
waited for four minutes the entire
shooting episode of six minutes the
Broward County deputy was outside heard
the shots waited outside with his gun
for four minutes and did not enter the
school can attack ended with 17 dead
people including at least a dozen dead
kids and the Broward County sheriff's
deputy whose job it was he's the arm
school officer it is his job to drush
that to brush that guy he sat outside
and he didn't do anything
he sat outside and did nothing we also
know by the way that the schools the
schools tape the school's security
mechanism was tape-delayed so whatever
they were seeing on the cameras was
twenty minutes running twenty minutes
behind this guy was sitting outside
apparently he heard the gunshots and he
did nothing even the Broward County
Sheriff himself Steve Israel
acknowledged this yesterday in a press
conference shocking stuff here is what
Israel had to say Scott Peterson was
absolutely on campus for lesson two it
through this entire event he was armed
he was in uniform but what I saw was a
deputy arrived at the west side of
building 12 take up a position and he
never went in and he never went in okay
this guy's sat outside and he did not go
in now a lot of people today on the Left
aren't doing this room because they want
to make this about the guns and not
about the fact that there was an armed
officer there who did nothing instead of
it
because they want to make it about the
availability of weapons they say well
can you blame them this guy not charging
yes I can blame him and I don't have to
be a police officer or soldier to blame
him I wasn't in that situation I also
didn't volunteer to become an employee
of the Broward County Sheriff's Office
and become an armed school officer that
is this guy's only job you had one job
and when time came you coward and it
wasn't just that okay are you ready for
this this gets even worse it's get
significantly worse this is breaking in
the last 15 minutes CNN reporting quote
when Coral Springs police officers this
different district when Coral Springs
police officers arrived at Marjory
Stoneman Douglas High School in parkland
Florida On February 14th in the midst of
the school shooting crisis many officers
were surprised to find not only that
Broward County sheriff's deputy Scott
Peterson the arm school resource officer
had not entered the building but that
three other Broward County sheriff's
deputies were also outside the school
and had not entered the deputies had
their pistols drawn and they were behind
their vehicles the sources said and not
one of them
had gone into the school so while this
monster was roamings classroom to
classroom with his rifle mowing down
students for deputies for armed
uniformed deputies were sitting outside
then get in there try and save the kids
then get there to try and rescue the
kids after the COS had been shot they
waited for an entirely new Police
Department to get there and go inside
there's something fishy going on here
folks there is something going on here
because that I promise you when people
sign up to be sheriff's deputies they're
not doing so thinking that they're gonna
cower behind a car they're doing so
thinking that they want to help save
people so there's something going on and
this thing Steve Israel knows the answer
and he ain't telling us Steve Israel
discounted this sheriff he knows exactly
what happened here and he is not telling
us there's a rumor online that I
hesitate to report because I don't know
that it's well substantiated this has
more to do with sheriff's policy than
anything else but we're gonna find out
because something happened here where
four deputies were sitting outside with
their guns drawn and a monster inside
massacring children and they didn't go
inside they're gonna told me that's the
NRA his fault they're gonna tell me
that's Dana lashes fault you're gonna
tell me that's my fault living in Los
Angeles and my guns in my safe you're
gonna tell me that's the fault of
$100,000,000 owners who weren't there
many of whom would have run
the shooter and tried to do something
just like what happened in the in the
Texas Church shooting where an armed
citizen took down the bad guy bad guy
who's just an armed citizens and a hell
of a lot more than any of these cops did
in Broward County this is insanity I
don't tell you something that's even
more insane here's something that's even
more insane again remember just a couple
of days ago it was this schmuck Steve
Israel who's standing on stage amidst a
bunch of the citizens from Broward
County and shouting at Dana lash and
telling aunt Dana lash that it was her
fault that all this had happened that it
was the NRA s fault that all this has
happened Virtue's signaling and
posturing about how we just need to get
guns out of the hands of bad people well
the guns were in the hands of the right
people but they didn't do a damn thing
according to CNN is the worst law
enforcement failure in modern American
history seventeen dead people because
there are cops waiting outside who
didn't go in there and here's the thing
that's amazing about this okay so I
ripped down the CNN special because I
thought that it was a an emotional setup
I think that it was it was an emotional
setup it was specifically designed to
destroy the the proponents of second
Amendment rights it was I thought this
reputable I thought it had no news value
it was just two minutes of hate it was
due to Orwell's two minutes hate here's
what makes it even worse well Israel was
doing this there were questions rakers
all this came out this morning there
were questions that came out over the
last couple days about what Israel knew
and when he knew it because now we know
he's admitting it full on that he had
two deputy there who didn't pull his gun
and didn't go inside and there now we're
finding out from CNN there were three
more deputies so the question is when
did he know that did he only find out
about that after he ripped Dana lash to
shreds and after he ripped the NRA to
shreds and after he blamed Second
Amendment proponents for what happened
or did he know that while he was on that
stage and is he's such a dishonest piece
of human debris that he went on that
stage and blend everybody but himself
when he's the guy in power he's the guy
with star on his chest he's the man
responsible for taking care of those
kids that is his duty that is his job
that is what he was hired to do that is
what he's paid to do that's only got his
pension from and that guy was standing
at it so when did he know it well
fortunately for us CNN reports isn't me
reporting it in daily wire reporting it
in the right-wing piece of news media
reporting at eight Fox News this is CNN
okay according to Coral Springs City man
Mike good rung on February 15th the day
after the shooting this is a direct
quote from CNN okay
direct quote from CNN the choral City
Springs manager city manager chewed out
Steve Israel over that malfeasance on
February 15th he approached him the day
after the shooting he said my people
told me that they got there and your
people were outside doing nothing which
means that not only did Israel probably
know it he was informed of it directly
by somebody else and then a week later
he went on national television and
ripped somebody who had nothing to do
with it and blame them for the problem
how disgusting is that how repulsive is
that I mean that is just the level of
moral despicable 'ti necessary to do
that is just astonishing so two levels
of absolute degradation moral
degradation one for police officers
waiting outside while kids get mowed
down one guy inside with a gun for
people outside with guns that's that's
level number one which is the worst and
then level number two is the cover-up
where you blame everybody but yourself
when you're the one responsible for it
absolutely horrifying absolutely
horrifying in every possible way now
what if the media done about this well
the media of course have continued to
blame the NRA the media have continued
to suggest that its gun owners second
Amendment advocates everywhere who are
doing all of this you know President
Trump said today he was speaking at CPAC
and President Trump said today that the
Second Amendment was under threat and
Jessie single guy who I'm friendly with
from a former leave New York magazine he
and I got into it on Twitter because he
said what kind of nonsense is that the
Second Amendment is under threat well
that same Steve Israel was on stage
calling for a full ban on semi-automatic
rifles which is any working rifle in the
United States that's not a bolt action
or a lever action rifle or a muzzle
loaded rifle it's a basically are
calling for a vast ban on the most
common guns in the United States and
then telling us that's not a violation
of the Second Amendment and we're
supposed to feel comfortable with this
you roll out a 24/7 propaganda effort by
the news media to say that guns are
responsible for something well it's
pretty clear the authorities didn't do
their job and I'm supposed to feel
comfortable with you guys
so here's here's the case you're making
to me Steve Israel here's the case
you're making to me Barack Obama here's
the case you're making to me all the
folks in the media on the left in the
case that you're making to me today is
the FBI failed twice to do anything
about this school shooter and then the
Broward County Sheriff's Office failed
39 times to do anything about that
shooter and then there were armed people
from the Broward County Sheriff's Office
there four of them apparently and they
didn't do anything about the shooter and
I'm supposed to hand over my gun to you
I'm supposed to hand over my ability to
defend myself to you why in why in blue
blazing hell would I do that why would I
hand over my only ability to protect
myself to people who are going to stand
outside with the guns that I gave up and
not rush the shooter again the people in
the media are just it Scott is there a
lot Steve in general rather the the
people in the the the people in the
media have been attempting to spin away
from this story all day now it's even
worse obviously because it's not just
one officer it's for the way they've
been spinning away from this so lawrence
O'Donnell was the worst lawrence
O'Donnell last night goes on TV and he
says how can you expect one man to
charge into the line of fire
even if he's wearing a uniform I love
these same people who say that the cops
are racists the cops are pathetic we
shouldn't trust the cops we can never
trust the cops and now all of a sudden
they're the big defenders of cops they
only like cops when cops don't actually
do anything apparently so this cop
didn't run in he didn't do anything so
lawrence O'Donnell says you know why he
didn't do that because the muzzle
velocity of a rifle is three times the
muzzle velocity of a handgun so the
officers gun had a lower muzzle velocity
than the shooters rifle did that any
idea how ridiculously stupid this is
this defense so is the idea that this
guy would be able to avoid a fired
bullet from a handgun does he have
matrix likes ability as soon as he picks
up an AR suddenly he can bend over
backwards like Keanu Reeves and make
sound waves in the error behind the
bullet is that the idea here let's say
they're standing a hundred feet apart
we'll do a quick back of the envelope
math here our typical rifle fires about
3900 feet per second that's the muzzle
velocity is about 3,900 feet per second
a typical handgun is about 1,300 feet
per second what's it they were standing
100 feet from one another let's say that
he ran into the hallway and they're
standing a hundred feet from one another
that means that if they fire
the bullets simultaneously the bullet
fired from the rifle would hit
approximately five one hundredths of a
second before the bullet fired from the
handgun are you telling me it's purely
impossible for that officer to get in
there they'd have a five five hundredths
of a second advantage cuz not even fast
enough for you to blink your eyes hey
you literally would not even see that
okay that's how fast it is and yet we're
told that this is the deciding factor or
do we have tremendous we have to have
tremendous sympathy for this officer
again I wouldn't want to be in that
position as an officer but that's why I
didn't sign up to be an officer and if I
had a gun as a civilian I hoped that I
would have the balls to rush in there
and try to do something but if you're
gonna make the case the government
should have the only authority to stop
mass shooters if you're trying to make
the case that we shouldn't arm teachers
or we shouldn't arm private security
guards or that citizens shouldn't be
armed there you have to do better than
that you're gonna have to do better than
that
but who's really to blame on all of us
who's really to blame according to the
media of course it's always Republican
it's obviously Republicans who are a
problem so the boycotts are now
beginning against the NRA so even though
we've learned in the past 48 hours that
the authorities failed on every single
possible level multiple times who's
getting blame the NRA so a bunch of
folks on the Left are now going to
people who have business deals with the
NRA and urging them to cut off the
business deals so enterprise rent-a-car
announced today that they would end the
discount that they have for NRA members
they're just a business deal and
surprise rents Carter tweeted thank you
for contacting us all three of our
brands this would be enterprise-d alamo
national have entered have ended the
discount for NRA members this change
will be effective March 26 thank you
again for reaching out kind regards
Michael so there we are now it turns out
that we're gonna as our corporations are
gonna be pressured to blame gun owners
law-abiding gun owners remembers the NRA
for this remember if the NRA played any
role in these shootings the most role
the NRA played in these shootings was
having shooting classes for J ROTC
students and also training the guy who
took down the the shooter in Texas not
one of these shooters has been a member
of the NRA not one and yet the NRA is
being blamed for this and Scott Israel
is not just amazing wasn't just
enterprise by the way Hertz came out and
they've said now they're gonna
disassociate from the NRA now listen
we'll get to the NRA in a second how the
NRA has handled this
because I don't agree with everything
that was said yesterday at CPAC I was at
CPAC it was wonderful thank you for
coming it was great to see all of you I
had blast talking to all the students
and young people and I think I I hope I
said some important things to the media
about how they've treated people who are
gun owners and what they can do to help
stop the spate of mass shootings but I
don't agree with everything that Wayne
LaPierre or even Dana with good friends
I said yesterday at CPAC but the media's
drive to blame this on Gunners is just
insane so Trevor Noah
the execrable host over on Comedy
Central the least funny man in America I
can safely say that because Samantha B's
the least funny woman in America so he's
the least funny man in America Trevor
Noah and he says that Marco he's mocks
Marco Rubio because Marco Rubio went to
this CNN show trial where people are
baying for the head of Marco Rubio and
begging for the head of Dana last parent
they are calling her a murderer and and
Trevor Noah ripped into Marco Rubio all
the really powerful moments and now
thanks to that father we all know what
Marco Rubio's face looks like when he's
crapping his pants looked like a dad
trying to explain to his son why he
cheated on his mom
he was like you say you see Cameron
sometimes a politician has needs and
and when the NRA opens their wallet it's
so hard to resist
you know this reminded me of it reminds
me of the reaction a lot of men had to
the me2 movement you know when people
were like if we carry on like this we're
gonna live in a world where men can't
even hit on their female staff that is
what we want okay okay so this is this
idea that Rubio is of course the bad guy
here I'll be interested to hear what
Trevor Noah has to say about the law
enforcement officers already you're
seeing the the spins starting from the
left that what this really demonstrates
is that a good guy with the gun can't
stop a bad guy with a gun no what it
demonstrates is that a useless person
with the gun cannot stop a bad guy with
the gun
it does not demonstrate the good guy
with the gun can't stop a bad guy with
the gun because it's always been a good
guy with the gun stopping a bad guy with
the gun the problem here is he didn't
have a good guy where were the good guys
you were absent they were missing and
the media treatment here is so egregious
it's so egregious and again they just
keep hosting these students to go on
there and the ones who they keep hosting
or of course the ones who are the
biggest advocates for for gun control
there was one parkland student who was
he he was this is one of zyf actually
the next the next clip where he was
talking about Trump and suggesting of
course that Trump listens to people like
the NRA who are putting blood money in
his pocket I wonder how how Samuels
wife's parents voted for a County
Sheriff in Broward County actually
hearing about here's Samuels life
blaming Trump for the NRA giving him
money or somesuch everyone saw in his
note card and said I hear you and I
think he did hear us but he wasn't
listening to us mainly because he only
listens to people putting money in his
pocket in this case blood money my
friend's blood a lot of my classmates
blood and it's I don't think we're gonna
get far with him right now
the NRA does not have blood on its hands
to use this kind of language as I said
yesterday at CPAC it is despicable and
vile and I don't care if you have
suffered in terms of whether it makes
that statement moral or not I care if
you've suffered in terms of your
suffering I feel terrible for anybody
who's suffered had to go through this
but again as I said yesterday it does
not make what you are saying moral it is
not moral okay it is not moral to blame
keep
we're not responsible for bad actions
for bad actions that is an immoral act
it's an immoral thing now I want to take
a quick note here before I move on and I
do want to debunk something that's been
going around there's been a lot of talk
about CNN scripting the people at the
Town Hall now CNN was biased in that
Town Hall they knew full well that this
was going to be a crowd bang for
anti-gun measures they knew that these
people were going to mistreat Rubio they
knew that these folks were gonna
mistreat Dana lash they knew that
there's gonna be screams they didn't do
anything to shut it down
they knew that all the people who are
asking questions we're gonna be anti-gun
advocates they knew exactly how this was
gonna go I know this because I know
people at CNN okay they knew exactly how
this was gonna go but the notion that
this was all scripted that all these
students were told what to say by
producers at CNN that is not so true so
the right-wing media I think have
suggested something that isn't true and
I want to point that out what probably
happened is that these students were
asked to boil down their questions into
little pieces of paper that they could
read now is there a bias to that clearly
there is because Cameron Caskey the
student cast to get in Rubio on stage
and said to him that he was like the
Parkland shooter himself which is again
just morally deficient in every possible
way that that was allowed to go on for
minutes at a time but some of the
pro-gun students were told to basically
condense their questions into the small
assembly so there is a bias but the bias
does not extend to CNN producers were
actually writing out the questions for
the students there's not any clear
evidence of that at this point Jake
Tapper says that this is normally how
it's done
and from what I've seen at other town
halls that's not a surprise okay so I
want to get to the editor and responds
to this now and the NRA response to this
has been some good and some bad
so first of all I let Dana lash speak
for herself so Dana as I've said before
is a friend of mine I'm gonna try and
put my biases aside here because I like
Dana I think she's a nice gal and and
talk in all honesty about the the NRA
response so Dana was at CPAC yesterday
and she was talking about what happened
at the CNN Town Hall and here's what she
had to say
you heard that town hall last night they
cheered the confiscation of firearms and
it was over 5,000 people I had to have a
security detail to get out I wouldn't
been able to exit that if I did not have
a private security detail
there were people rushing the stage and
screaming burn her and I came there to
talk to solutions and I still am going
to continue that conversation on
solutions as the NRA has been doing for
before I was alive okay
so that story is confirmed by the fact
that you can actually hear in the audio
he played it yesterday people shouting
out at her that she's a murderer while
she's on stage and Jake Tapper nobody
CNN stops it and says guys calm down
we're trying to have a discussion here
instead it just continues and jake has
said online well I didn't want to I
didn't want to tell people what they
could feel it's not a matter of telling
people what they can feel it's a matter
of providing good news stuff right it's
a matter of good providing good news
content it's a matter of ensuring that
you are not just doing a propaganda
special and CNN failed in that I mean
I've never seen a propaganda special
quite like that on national TV now Dana
in response to this said something that
I think is not true and I don't think is
used for good she said that many people
in the media love mass shootings now
maybe what she meant by this is that
there are people in the ratings Bureau
who look at the ratings they say look at
our ratings today they're really great
but if what you meant by this is that
people in the media are fine with mass
shootings or want to or are happy about
mass shootings then that of course is
not true she should have been a lot more
specific in her language sure she said
at CPAC yesterday a lot of folks in the
media love mass shootings now I will say
again I think there are people in the
media who use mass shootings as a lever
for their favorite politics but I don't
think anybody in the mass media is
sitting around going god I hope 15 kids
die today at a school I think that's
that's a slander and members of the
media and I say that because I think the
media have been slandering me I think
the media been slandering Dana I think
the media have been slandering everybody
on the right by suggesting that we have
bad motivations then we don't care when
kids get shot so I think it's silly for
us to suggest people on the left own
Carolyn kids get shot we cannot have a
good conversation a useful conversation
in this country if we keep saying the
other side doesn't care when kids get
shot if you really believe that your
political opponents are such evil human
beings that they don't care when kids
die we can't have a conversation at all
it's the end of our country there will
be a civil war if you actually believe
the person who lives next door to you
doesn't care if your child dies in a
bloody hail of bullets then you're gonna
be much more likely to pick up a gun and
go after that guy so just put it that
way here's Dana saying this yesterday at
CPAC now I'm gonna say something that
some people are going to say is
controversial so I'll say it really
slowly so all the people on the platform
in the back can hear me loud and clear
many in legacy media love mass shootings
you guys love it now I'm not saying that
you love the tragedy but I am saying
that you love the ratings
crying white mothers are ratings gold to
you and many in the legacy media in the
back ok did but the suggestion here is
that they care more about their ratings
than they do about the dead kids I don't
think that's right I don't think that's
right listen I think they care too much
about the ratings I ripped them from the
stage yesterday suggesting that they
should put their morality ahead of their
ratings and stop showing the names and
faces of the shooters but I wouldn't
suggest that they actually like the
shootings that they actually want the
shootings to happen like that I don't
think is appropriate wayne lapierre from
the other eye did this to again i think
this doesn't actually serve the NRA's
interest what the nra should be doing
right now is saying listen we want to
stop this stuff as much as you do and
it's insulting and disgusting when you
suggest that we don't but to reverse the
charge and suggest the people in the
media actually like the mass shootings
it's too much Wayne LaPierre did the
same thing yesterday again I don't think
this is the smart move few leads don't
care not one whit about America's school
system and school of children if they
truly cared what they would do is they
would protect them for them it's not a
safety issue it's a political issue ok
so again this is this is a mistake it's
a tactical mistake it's a moral mistake
and you're getting it from the other
side so now you have both sides
screaming at each other the worst people
on earth keith Ellison of course comes
out and he says the Wayne LaPierre has
blood on his hands this is the stick
that the entire Democratic Party has
fallen into he doesn't want to talk
about the fact that since the assault
weapons ban lapse in 2004 we've seen a
239 percent increase in gun related
deaths he doesn't want to talk about the
blood that has spilled all over his
hands because of the Lexx policies that
he's pushing he wants to make people
afraid and he wants to tell people lies
and distortions rather than deal with
the fact that he is in Sicily and
trafficking in fear in order to line the
pockets of his clients in the gun
Manning this stuff is just
it's just gross and it's not worthwhile
it doesn't do credit to the NRA it
doesn't do credit to the NRA's opponents
doesn't do it credit to any of that now
Allison Cammarata had on Dana lash today
and that want to show you two clips of
that because one of them I think
demonstrates the lack of credibility on
the part of the media and the other
demonstrates why it's a mistake to
castigate the media and say they don't
care about mass shootings which of
course is not true here's the first one
Allison cammarata saying listen when you
say that we like mass shootings that's
just nonsense and here I have to agree
with Allison Cammarata you think well I
said many I said many not all but I do
think that the way that loves the
network and I do think that the way that
I do think that many in the media do
because they like the ratings aspect of
it and that's true because it's
wall-to-wall coverage they put the
murderers face up on on loop none on
televisions all across America more than
they discuss-- even the victims or
survivors
I mean if an individual's name has been
mentioned and is still mentioned on your
network you know it's just it's just
malicious actually that you would say
that I don't know anybody in the media
who likes mass shootings you're wrong on
every single level okay so this is why
okay so this is why Dana shouldna said
what she said about the media now Dana
says but you say that about me right you
guys say that I'm a murderer
you guys yell at me you say burn her you
say that I'm responsible for these mass
shootings and now Allison camera are the
shoes on the other foot in Allison
Cammarata can't even acknowledge that
this is exactly what the media have been
doing which they have right so here is
Dana being in the right and camerata
being in the wrong this is 19 yeah you
you're saying that it's malicious but
yet on your network you've allowed
accusations against me and millions of
law-abiding Americans and to be indicted
as child murderers I've watched you
Allison understood that you have this
very timeslot and you've done corrected
on your network it's not I don't believe
you Dan I don't know any of you that I
did I don't do nothing and making it
even easier for these horrifying people
to get guns because if you can't get
elected without taking money from child
murderers why are you running hey guys
are you gonna be able to go back to
school right we played that clip on the
show the other day so here's Allison
Cammarata saying that no one's called
you a murderer that kid call
hurry murder right on allison camera
show and allison Cammarata sat by and
did nothing so that is not so again
dishonesty dishonesty and more
dishonesty from the media that doesn't
mean that people on the right should
fall into the trap of accusing their
political opponents of being bad human
beings except insofar as the people on
the left accuse us of not caring about
dead kids okay by the way another piece
of breaking news this is just how many
red flags do you have to miss here and
then standing outside for deputies I
mean it's just it's heartbreaking it's
heartbreaking somebody should go to jail
for this they really should here is this
is a call according to the New York
Times a transcript excerpt from Adam
Goldman of the New York Times of an FBI
tipster warning the Parkland shooter in
January quote okay I just figure I was
talking with the operator and she
transferred me I'm like I said to her I
don't know how to go about this but on
the Instagram account I have I wouldn't
say he's crazy by blood but I would
consider him bleep he's only 18 he's got
the mental capacity of a 12 to 14 year
old his mother just passed away on the
first of November he's got Instagram
accounts he started off saying he wanted
to kill himself so what I did was I
called the Parkland which is where he
lived Parkland Police Department I spoke
to an officer I didn't hear anything I
left a message I gave him all the
information I had and then just recently
now he switched it he wants to kill
people and then he put that on his
Instagram in about two days later he
took it off if you go on to his
Instagram pages you'll see all the guns
he's variant Isis I'm afraid this is
something that's gonna happen because he
doesn't have mental capacity he can't
he's so outraged if someone talks to him
about certain things and he had pulled
the rifle on his mother before she
passed away because she wanted to get
money um and the whole and another
problem is that he's 18 and his mother's
life insurance policy is coming in he's
gonna receive 25 grand from that and
then 21 24 up to 30 he's receiving 25
grand every year after that he went out
and took money out of his mother's
account I don't know how he got the
debit card but he did he took the money
and then the Social Security money right
and he bought all these rifles and ammo
he posted pictures of them on the
Instagram this is a transcript of a call
to the FBI transcript will called the
FBI he never graduated high school he's
thrown out of all these schools because
he would pick up a chair and just throw
it at somebody a teacher or student
because he didn't like the way they were
talking to him I just think about you
know getting into a school and just
shooting the place up direct transcript
to the FBI
nobody did a damn thing and you're gonna
tell me I'm supposed to give it my gun
to these clowns to these jokers I'm
supposed to give up my ability to fend
myself to these morons you've got to be
freaking kidding me
never
going to happen not going to happen all
right well when we come back I have a
couple more things to say on this will
do some things I like things I hate will
do the mailbag as well but first we're
gonna have to go over to daily wire.com
and subscribe for $9.99 a month you get
a subscription to daily wired.com and
when you do you get the rest of the show
live you can part of the mailbag today
so you can send us questions live in the
mailbag right now you can also go over
to our site and you get the annual
subscription that means the and all of
those things plus the leftist here is
hot or cold tumblr the greatest of all
beverage vessels I feel refreshed
amazing so check it out
at $9.99 a month for the monthly and the
99 for the annual if you want the cup
then you have to get the annual
subscription if you just want to listen
later then iTunes SoundCloud please
subscribe loops review subscribe / a
youtube channel as well we are the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
all righty so um you know what let's
just go right to things I like things I
hate in the mailbag because I know
honestly I'm emotion doubt yeah at this
point I'm not I'm not wanting to be to
run on feelings it's not that that's
what that's not the gas that I usually
have in my tank but this has been such a
disturbing upsetting pathetic week for
the country really a terrible week for
the country the last week and a half the
way that Americans are treating each
other and seeing each other and it's
really heartbreaking to watch so let's
just go to the mailbag and since it
first let's do things I like in things I
hate so first things I like so there's a
movie that came and went and wasn't
really seen by a lot of folks called
thank you for your service with miles
teller I really like miles teller a lot
as an actor it's basically a new version
I would say of the best years of our
lives which is one of the great coming
home for more movies of all time Best
Picture 1946 now this one is not that
but it's about three soldiers who are
coming home from war in Iraq and they
all three have serious PTSD and how they
have to deal with it here's a little bit
the trailer you'll see the bomb unless
they want you to what you got I don't
see nothing now you don't see he feels
it
[Music]
so then the movie is is pretty gritty
it's it really doesn't focus too much
about what happened in a rocket it focus
a lot more about the adjustment home and
how there's a lot of the veterans who
are falling through the cracks which
certainly is true I guess it's a little
bit hard on the military but as somebody
who's never been through this I can't
really say that that that's for sure
whatever it is anything that that helps
propel more money to the VA more
resources to soldiers who are coming
home from war I'm very much in favor of
hopefully it's as accurate as possible
of course ok time for a quick thing that
I hate then we'll get to the mailbag so
the thing I hate today is the movie Lady
Bird so everybody loves this movie now
Mathis loves this movie
I know moles liked this movie which is
one reason to hate it but the movie Lady
Bird is getting all sorts of plaudits
because Greta Gerwig is the first-time
director and apparently if you're an
actress and you can also do a plot a
plausible job of direction then we think
that you're the greatest thing that ever
lived this movie I thought was
extraordinarily twy twy is just a word
meaning kind of cutesy
too cutesy by half all of the dialogue
is overwritten not it's you know the
performances are good all around but
every beat of the movie is predictable
they're a bunch of threads that are just
left hanging for no reason and the the
theme of the movie is actually nice
right I like it in spite of the theme of
the movie the scene the theme of the
movie is there's a girl who's basically
obnoxious she's an atheist and she is
pro-abortion and over the course of the
movie she learns that she should be less
obnoxious that's essentially the plot a
sunny bunch at the weekly substandard I
think put this well and the free beacon
I think that he put this well he said
this is basically an hour and a half
long version of Roseanne except the
film's a little bit nicer and that's
basically right the mom's kind of you
know the tough-talking
but but truthful one and the dad is the
pushover and the girls Peyman but so you
know if it's your cup of tea enjoy it
was not mine I didn't think that it was
any great shakes the fact that it's
nominated for Best Picture I think is a
little bit weak they should have
nominated for sure to the Florida
Project which is not nominated for Best
Picture they should have nominated that
they should have left this off the list
instead but yeah we'll show you a little
bit of the preview I suppose I think
I want to go where culture is like my
research or at least Connecticut or New
Hampshire and writers living above into
those schools anyway mom should just go
to City College you know with your work
ethic just go to City College and then
to jail and then back to City College
and then maybe you'd learn to pull
yourself off and not expect everybody
everything
Lady Bird is that your given day yeah in
quotes I gave it to myself it's given to
me by me Lady Bird always says that she
lives in the wrong side of the tracks
but I always thought that it was like a
metaphor but there are actual train
tracks okay so here's the good news
about the preview you just saw every
clever line in the film so most of the
cleverness in the film is actually in
that in that two and two minute segments
right there that one minute segment um
it's it I thought the move drag a little
bit not a fan okay I know there are
people who disagree but just man okay
time for time for some mailbag so if you
have questions now is your time to send
them in live if you're in our daily wire
chat room then you can send your
questions now okay Seth says hi Ben
I'm a pro Second Amendment gun-toting
Texan it seems the American values have
changed so much since the Second
Amendment was enacted is it possible
that in today's society we've too far
we're too far gone to be trusted with
the freedoms that so many have
sacrificed for well I would say that
there are a lot of people who are
certainly misusing their freedoms but
that's not a problem with freedom that's
a problem with virtue and it's our job
to re-encode virtue the solution to to
lack of virtue is not curtailing freedom
it's to reinstall virtue but those are
the two choices you're right those are
the two choices and this is why when
Liberty people who are cultural
libertarians now even governmental
libertarians I'm sort of a government to
libertarian but a cultural libertarians
people who say that community values
don't matter very much now that we're
atomized individuals when people on the
Left say that you can just destroy the
social fabric no problem then first you
no longer is an aspect of our common
heritage when people say that and
inevitably is going to lead to more
governmental tyranny or it's gonna lead
to a real collocation of virtue I vote
for virtue Parker says Haven I always
encounter liberals that say red states
consume more welfare than blue states is
this true and if so why so the answer is
yes this is true the reason this is true
is because there are federal welfare
programs that go to poor people there
are more people in red states than blue
states on per capita level okay so yes
that is true
it is also true that the people who are
voting for
the higher levels where wealth around
the federal level are not from the red
states so the people from the blue
states are whining about this maybe they
should stop voting for all the welfare
programs we could start there James has
been I keep hearing conservative
advocates of mental health reform
suggest the idea of bringing back the
ability to involuntarily commit people
deemed unfit and dangerous to society
what are your thoughts on the potential
abuses of such a practice how would you
suggest protecting against them so as
not to put individual Liberty at risk in
a similar fashion to overly restrictive
gun control laws enforcing punitive
measures against law-abiding citizens
this is a great question the answer is
that you have to have a certain burden
of proof so danger to self or others is
usually a pretty high burden of proof
involuntarily committing somebody even
for a 24 or 48-hour holds in the state
of California for example is actually
pretty difficult you have to show the
person's suicidal or that the person is
violent I assume that you'd have to show
the same thing to a judge and that
wouldn't just mean you going there and
testifying that's the case of the judge
you probably need some form of evidence
that that is the case and you'd have to
need more if you if it was based on
witness testimony it would have to be
more than one witness and you know the
truth is that I think judges are fairly
good at sussing masada I don't think
that you're facing as well if the worry
is that you're leftist family members
are going to forcibly prevent you from
getting guns by going and testifying in
front of a judge then you know maybe
that would happen once in a bajillion
tries I just I don't I don't see this as
a major problem maybe I'm wrong it's
possible that I'm wrong but this is why
you need a high evidentiary bar you can
set a high of an entry area bar by
suggesting that it's not just by
preponderance of the evidence that it's
beyond a reasonable doubt this is the
case for example like you get there
different standards of proof that you
have to meet beyond reasonable doubt is
usually a criminal standard
preponderance of the evidence usually a
civil standard but you can set up
whatever standard you want there
bradon's has been what is your opinion
on right-to-work states I'm an employee
of Washington State I'm forced to pay
union dues regardless of me joining a
union or not as expected Washington
state leans very low heavily to the left
with its policies and the Liberals
lifestyle choices so this of course is
true I used to do a show up in Seattle
and it is certainly the case that
Washington is a lefty state it is also
true in the state of California you have
to be a member of a union in order to
work in certain areas right to work
should be a constitutional amendment you
should be able to work in any industry
that you want to without being a member
of a union unions are fine in the
private sector when people are
voluntarily joining them and juanique
aren't being broken they are not good in
the public sector and the silly idiotic
legislative idea that you are going to
legislate do you have to be a member of
a union to work as a teacher undermines
the interests of students remember when
there's a public sector union the people
they are collectively bargaining against
are the taxpayer that's the person on
the other side of the table if you're in
a private sector Union and you are
collectively bargaining you're doing so
against the person who owns the business
who owns the federal government okay we
own the federal government which means
that every time a union bargains with
the federal government they're
bargaining with the taxpayer what makes
it worse is that when they're not
actually bargaining with your me they're
bargaining with elected representatives
and those elective representatives take
donations from whom from exactly the
people with whom they are bargaining so
that's not that's a pretty corrupt cycle
it's a good book called shadow bosses by
a friend my name--a Laurie factor that
goes into all of us Antonius has been I
live in Anaheim and while I agree that
many homeless people are mentally ill
I'm surrounded with homeless individuals
that are around my age and it is
visually obvious that they are on drugs
not mentally ill you can see where they
inject themselves in the rashes on their
bodies do you think that there is a
growing amount of homeless people due to
drugs rather than mental illness yes I
mean I have said that I think that a
huge percentage of people who are on the
streets are either drug addicts or
mentally ill or both that's obviously
true you can see it in the needles on
the streets now as I was walking a block
from my house the other day and I found
a needle on the street and it's just
it's just horrifying and this is you
know one of the arguments against
legalizing hard drugs that this excuse
your ability to reason and makes it so
you can't actually have free choice in
how you choose to behave and so we have
to live in that dramatically whatever it
is there's no excuse for people to be
living on the streets one of the ways
that you can clean up this problem is by
taking people who are living on the
streets and either putting them in a
facility against their will so they can
clean out and if they're mentally ill
doing that or if they're a drug addict
putting them in a facility where they
will clean out and be taken off of drugs
Ben says hi Ben I was just curious what
things led you to realize you were going
to marry your wife was there a specific
moment or factor that made you decide
that you were gonna pursue her how did
you actually propose to her so here's my
view of romance and this is a very
realistic view of romance I think the
first thing that has to happen is of
course there has to be physical
attraction you're not gonna want to talk
to the person if you think that they're
not attractive okay that is always the
first thing so when I first saw my wife
I thought this is a smoking hot person
so so that was the first thing that I
thought when she saw me by the way she
thought dorky but cute
was was the way and she that was that's
I think that's still a very flattering
response to my physical appearance but
that's how she felt about it she
actually thought I was a jackass when I
drove up it says I used to drive a 2006
GT Mustang convertible baby blue and so
I drove up in that and she thought oh
who is this Pete who is this jerk and
then I got out and I was wearing like
mom jeans and a beat-up polo shirt and
she's like oh I was just a nerd okay and
she was happy about that which is why I
love my wife um the reason that well
what made me think of this so number one
I could hold it an intelligent
conversation with her at number two we
had values in common so as I've said
before we dated for marriage that meant
that our first date was about free will
and determinism our second date was
about if I recall gun control in the
death penalty on our third date we
finally talked about TV shows so so
there was a heavy bias toward talking
about things that mattered to us we
talked a lot about our religious
heritage we talked a lot about how many
I mean I asked her on first date how
many kids she wanted right this is the
difference between dating for marriage
and dating to just date now in the
Orthodox community you're typically
dating for marriage because he can't
date for sex cuz that's not something
they're supposed to be doing so that
means that you actually have to date for
values which i think is a good thing
as a general matter and as a specific
matter actually Anne says dear Ben I've
been enjoying you in the daily wear for
the past six months after the crazy
election I started taking the Hillsdale
College Constitution 101 online being
frustrated when politicians MSM and
people toss around tidbits of the
Constitution to suit their agenda what
I've discovered is very few people
understand or have truly studied the
Constitution I know it's true for me my
question is about executive orders when
how and what is the criteria for their
use seem since FDR it's been used
regularly and maybe out of control the
answer is yes it has been used regularly
and yes it is out of control
so executive orders have existed since
George Washington but what an executive
order was designed to do is there was a
piece of legislation and it would say we
direct the president to go and impose
this law and so the president would then
write in order to like the three people
who worked for him this is very small
executive branch and say you three
people are authorized to go do it right
so it's just a question of filling in a
gap the law left but the law had to
mandate that the executive was to do
that now the executive does things like
President Obama saying he's not going to
enforce the law with dackel which is
unconstitutional nor the President of
the United States going into war on the
basis of an executive order where he
doesn't have the authority to do so so
that is that is you know absolutely in
in overreach on the
part of the the executive branch manthie
says you have said it's done to get the
rights at different ages such as how to
buy alcohol you must be at least 21 but
18 to vote do you believe the minimum
age to be president should be lowered
not really not really I think that maybe
it should be heightened actually but
when the minimum age to be President was
35 years old the average life expectancy
in the United States is probably 50 55
so 35 was probably the equivalent of 50
in our society so when in an age when
people who are 26 years old they're
still on mommy and daddy's insurance and
live at home and aren't married and have
no kids no I don't think we should
necessarily lower the age to be present
I wouldn't want
I wouldn't want like right now if one of
these kids from Parkland were to run
against Trump that kid might win that
seems not like a great idea to me
because I don't I mean the standards for
our presidency are so low already do we
need to lower them any further we just
had an election between Donald Trump and
Hillary Clinton is this something is
this what we want to do is this what we
want to do let's make it let's make it
more rigorous to become a candidate for
high office how about that Andrew says
hey Ben I recently had a civil
conversation with my classmate about gay
marriage I use your argument how the
federal government shouldn't be in the
business of marriage and main purpose of
marriage is the procreation of children
and it provides a stable foundation for
family and society she agreed with most
of my argument she didn't agree with it
completely because she believes tax the
gay married couple should still get the
same tax bonus as heterosexual married
couples do I said her I didn't know
about the specific issue and we ended
the conversation there how did I make a
counter-argument well if she already
accepts the idea that the federal
government only has an interest in
marriage because of raising families and
children then why should there be a
federal tax benefit that it that accrues
to you because you're sleeping with
someone with whom you are incapable of
having children naturally that doesn't
seem to me to make a whole hell of a lot
of sense I don't think it should be tax
benefits for any of this stuff by the
way I think the government
discriminating in favor of certain
couples and against other couples just
seems like a fool's errand at this point
I don't think anybody is having more
kids based on the tax benefits that
doesn't seem realistic to me but the
idea is that if you if the government is
gonna occur confer advantages based on
what it gets out of the deal the
government gets a lot out of the less
out of the deal from from gay couples
than it does from straight couples in
terms of childbearing and rearing
obviously by statistics and that will
always be true no matter what because
people like having sex and when straight
people have sex there's a chance of a
baby and when gay people have sex
presumably with each other there's no
chance of a baby just sorry about the
biology folks that's the way it works
okay final question Eric says dear mr.
Shapiro as a father with the young
daughter enrolled in my local New Jersey
School District I was so upset by the
media's handling of the Parkland school
shooting that I subscribe to daily wire
today as a way to fight back well I
appreciate it thank you is there more I
can do would you say my money helps
conservatives like ourselves fight the
disinformation being spewed on a daily
basis I mean I hope so that's what we do
on a daily basis I think that there are
a lot of people joining the NRA for
particularly this reason and I don't
think that's a terrible idea at all I
think you should go and talk to your
local school district about the safety
measures that are actually being taken
on campus but yeah I mean this is it
this is a real public opinion battle
that's being waged right now and every
little bit helps oh we appreciate
everybody who's joining up for the
memberships we couldn't do the show
without you so here's a hard PIP for a
hard pitch for becoming a subscriber the
reason we can do this business every day
is because you support us so please go
over and subscribe right now at Daley
wire.com okay we will be back here on
Monday try not to ruin the country
further in my absence it's already bad
enough so please just have a let's have
a safe quiet as happy as we can weekend
and we'll be back here on Monday I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Oliveira the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright for
publishing 2018